Do you have something you need to be doing
right now but are avoiding like the Plague?
Maybe you have a lot of stuff you need to
do but you just keep putting it off, and,
you distract yourself from the discomfort
of even thinking about it?
Have you ever thought about what it would
feel like if you actually completed all of
it?
Like you just took a day, from the moment
you woke up till the end of the day, you worked
hard, through motivation and determination,
and just crushed everything on your to-do
list?
Today we're going to talk about that.
I'm Joey and welcome to Better Ideas.
Being massively productive over a long period
of time can seem like an activity that many
people lack the motivation or focus to pull
off.
But what a lot of people don't realize is
they don't actually lack motivation or focus,
they're just not setting the right parameters
to foster an environment of productivity and
focus.
In order to have a day where you're massively
productive from start to finish - you have
to set yourself up for success.
So here are 5 techniques that I use when I
really need to get stuff done, and when I
use them together I notice I'm just far more
focused, far more motivated, and I actually
end up crushing everything on my to-do list.
Also, disclaimer: These techniques work best
for homework, office work, paperwork, anything
where you can sit down at a coffee shop or
at a desk.
Number One: Find your Sacred Space.
The Sacred Space is your particular geographical
location that you treat with the utmost respect.
It's your temple of productivity.
It could be a particular coffee shop that
you notice you work really well in, or it
could even be a certain corner in your house
that you notice you just have extra focus
in.
You just have to make sure that when you're
there, it's for studying and studying only.
Once you goof off in that spot - you've officially
desecrated the sacred place and it's no longer
sacred - you have to find a different place.
You ruined it.
My second technique is - Start Your Work First
Thing in the Morning.
If you're really serious about getting work
done that day, and it's really important to
you, don't check social media first thing
in the morning, don't go on your phone - just
go to the sacred space as soon as possible
and start hitting the books and getting to
work.
As I've mentioned in previous videos, willpower
is a finite resource that depletes with every
single decision you make throughout the day,
so, in the morning, you have an abundant amount
of willpower that you can use at your disposal.
So just channel that glorious amount of willpower,
and just hyper-focus it into being productive.
Step number three is to Make A Proper Checklist.
You need a roadmap as to where you're going
- and making a good checklist is a lot more
than just writing all your tasks in random
order and putting a little tick-box next to
them.
You have to organize, prioritize and streamline
every single thing on that list into it's
most basic component.
I get into a lot more detail on how, exactly,
to make this checklist in a previous video
(I'll put the link in the description).
Number four is to use the Pomodoro Technique.
(Pomodoro technique...
I don't really know how to pronounce it.
Pomodro?...
Pomo-door-oh?...
Pum-oh-diroh...
Totoro.)
So basically you work for 25 minutes and take
a 5 minute break doing some type of non-mentally-hyperactive
activity.
This reduces the amount of mental strain associated
with high levels of concentration and allows
you to work harder for longer.
Technique number Five is to Set a Final Alarm
to the particular time that you need to start
thinking about something else.
Now this one seems kind of obvious, but a
lot of people neglect it and don't really
realize its importance.
I know in my own life - when I have a meeting
or a class sometime late at night and I'm
trying to get homework done earlier in that
day, I'm always thinking of that looming thing
I have to do, and not all my attention is
focused on my present work.
So in order to have the most effective work
session, you have to really free up things
like that - free up mental RAM, don't think
about the things you have to do in the future,
just focus on the now.
So that's why you have to delegate the mental
RAM or your responsibilities - to things like
alarms.
So once you set that in place, you don't have
to worry about it anymore - you can focus
100% of your attention on the task at hand
and really get things done and hone your focus.
Most people are familiar with at least one
of these techniques - but very few people
use all of them at the same time.
And the people I do know who've incorporated
3 or more of these things into their dail
work routine are some of the most productive
people I've ever met.
So give it a try - maybe you have a dark cloud
of looming responsiblities hanging over you
causing you to be stressed, anxious, whatever...
Well, by properly utilizing these techniques
and incorportating them in your study or work
session - you can be sure that your focus
will be honed, your productivity game will
be off the charts, so you can chip away at
that mountain of responsibilities until it's
a little pile of dust lying at the feet of
you - the victor.
If you liked this video and want to see me
make more, be sure to hit that Subscribe button
down below.
(incoherent).
And if you have any ideas for future videos
or requests or suggestions or anything, at
all, leave it in the comments section below
- I'd be happy to answer.
Also follow us on Facebook, Instagram, and
Twitter.
Facebook one is BetterIdeasTV, the Instagram
is BetterIdeasDaily, and the Twitter is also
BetterIdeasTV.
Yep I was right.
Catch ya in the next video.